il y a un instant à la pause tu sens une
tension incroyable actuellement ben
partirulement enfin aujourd'hui dans les
jours qui viennent de se passer parce
que le Hamas a appelé à une journée de
la colère c'est ça aujourd'hui
effectivement quand le
Hamas fait ce type de déclaration
d'abord c'est qu'il est un peu perdu il
sait plus très bien quoi faire il sent
bien qu'il est en porte à fau vis-à-vis
de toute la population les populations
occidentales euh donc il appelle à cette
journée de la colère de façon à ce que
tous tous les esprits entre guillemets
mais l'esprit faible passe à l'action et
là on a la caractéristique à mon avis
hein je sais pas ce que va dire
l'enquête mais du fait de qu'est-ce qui
peut se passer quand un un un un esprit
faible alors peut-être qu'il cherchait
un professeur qui voulait se venger mais
en tout cas il y a une action qui est
une action terroriste pour marquer une
une une une cofraternité avec ces
terroristes et c'est contre ça qu'il
faut lutter il faut lutter contre ça
évidemment lesisraéliens lutent contre
ça euh
les le Hamas est responsable de tout il
est responsable des du carnage qui a été
fait en Israël il est responsable des
morts qui sont en ce
moment à l'intérieur de la bande de Gaza
il est responsable des attentats qui va
qui vont se passer sur le sol français
sur tous les sols occidentaux
qui n'acceptent pas
forcément ce type d'attitude vous savez
nous sommes face à à une
guerre bon les mots sont grands mais une
guerre civil tion qui oppose un système
de vie qui est le nôtre c'est-à-dire on
aime voir nos les les les filles chez
nous avec les cheveux au vent on aime
nous boire un coup de Bordeaux le soir
après le bureau en discutant on aime
nous écouter de la musique ce qui
s'oppose à toutes les valeurs qui sont
en face de nous de ces ces hommes de
daesh ces hommes de l'État islamique qui
eux on l'a vu rappelez-vous il y a
quelques années quand daesh avait créé
un territoire rappelez-vous ce qui se
passait sur ce territoire donc voilà on
va se retrouver de plus en plus
confronté à ce type de situation ce que
je veux dire c'est qu'il ne faut pas
céder c'est-à-dire que à la fois nos
policiers bien sûr nos forces de l'ordre
nos militaires mais aussi la justice
doivent
réagir avec violence avec force il est
évident que
quand l'assassin de Madame elimi est
relâché quelques semaines ou quelques
mois
après après avoir assassiné cette femme
l'avoir jeté par la fenêtre en crant
labas Allah laakbar parce qu'on dit
qu'elle a qu'il a un
dérèglement qu'il a quelque chose dans
la tête qui ne marche pas il est certain
que ça ça peut encourager des vocations
je pense que à tout point de vue il faut
être extrêmement strict il faut punir il
faut il faut se battre et il faut
évidemment protéger bien sûr nos
enseignants qui sont de plus en plus
exposés et puis et puis nous tous tous
ceux qui ont ont une parole je pense à
mon camarade là tous ceux qui ont une
parole qui est une parole forte pour
s'opposer à ce type de d'action
justement Ramous moi je suis j'ai vu ton
poste j'ai je pense et tu sais quoi tu
me l'as envoyé parce que c'est vrai que
pens la même chose moi quand j'ai vu ça
je vois des trucs là sur les sur les sur
les réseaux la mort aux Juifs mort aux
Arabes mais c'est c'est quoi ça on est
où là c'est c'est c'est quoi ça mais
c'est moi c'est ce qui m'a poussé à
faire ma vidéo en fait c'est c'est la
peur qu'il se passe quelque chose comme
il vient de se passer à race en fait
parce que moi j'en ai j'en ai j'en ai
marre de de ce 8 mai j'en ai marre de
ces fausses justifications moi j'ai de
la peine peu importe l'origine de la
personne quand un enfant se fait égorger
je lu demande pas sa carte d'identité ça
c'estàd que moi j'ai de la peine ce qui
s'est passé en Israël c'est un attentat
ce qui vient de se passer en France
c'est un attentat on a le droit d'avoir
de la peine mais c'est pas un match
parismseille et ce qui vient de se
passer en France c'est malheureusement
on verra l'enquête mais je parle que
pour ma personne je parle pas au nom de
tous les musulmans et moi j'ai grandi
dans un pays qui est la France j'ai
grandi dans un pays où on m'a inculqué
des valeurs qui sont liberté égal
fraternité j'ai grandi avec des juifs
avec des noirs des musulmans des
chrétiens des bouddhistes des blancs des
homosexuels des hétérosexuels et ma mère
m'a inculqué l'islam qui est une
religion de paix ces gens-là n'ont rien
à voir avec la paix ces gens-là sont sur
l'autoroute de la connerie sont sortis à
la première sortie ils sont dans la
bêtise totale ils ne représentent rien
sauf leur monstruosité et c'est pour ça
que moi j'ai voulu appeler à la paix
parce que en 2023 quand tu as ne
serait-ce qu'une petite caisse de
résonance c'est ça je sais pas comment
tu fais pour rester sens sur les
on est beaucoup sur les réseaux tous les
deux et toi encore plus que moi tu sens
sur les ré tu sens qu'il y a un truc qui
monte là c'est incroyable là là pour moi
on a pris un tournant c'est ça moi je
l'ai senti parce que sur les réseaux
c'était plus comme un certain un certain
temps c'était de la compassion là
c'était de c'était de la hargne c'était
de la haine et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui on en vient à ça et c'est
pour ça qu'aujourd'hui dans notre pays
on organise la Coupe du monde de rugby
on organise les Jos on attend quoi qui a
une boucherie donc moi pour moi chacun a
sa responsabilité et bien sûr que je
condamne bien sûr que pour moi c'est
horrible ce qui s'est passé en Israël
c'est un attentat il y a pas à chercher
des fausses excuses c'est un attentat
c'est horrible et bien sûr moi j'ai de
la peine pour un enfant qui soit
israélien qui soit palestinien qui soit
français qui soit peu importe son
origine moi j'ai j'ai j'ai un pote hier
qui qui éta avec moi là Momo que vous
connaissez qui VI me voir qui est enu il
me disait que dans les et c'est ça il me
disait nous dans les dans les quartiers
au contraire tout se passe bien pour
l'instant vraiment euh au contraire il y
a des a des gens avec desquipa il y a
des gens avec avec voilà euh qui font
qui qui qui vont à la mosquée il y a des
gens qui vont à la synagogue au
contraire ça se passe très très bien et
il m'a dit voilà je suis il est au cœur
des des quartiers pour l'instant on sent
que ça se passe bien dans les quartiers
mais c'est sur surtout sur les réseaux
c'est incroyable cette haine et ça mais
c'est une méthode pardon hein mais c'est
une méthode de de communication Cyrile
qui existe depuis des décennies méthode
de communication des Frères musulmans
c'estàd qu'il s'empare d'un d'un fait il
s'emparent d'une situation et en fait il
leur but est de semer le discord de de
détruire le tissu même de nos sociétés
de faire en sorte que lui moi nous nous
opposions lui musulmanans moins Juifs
nous nous opposions parce
que ils vont en tirer le suc c'est ça et
il ne faut pas être DUP de ça c'est VI
nos enfants les enfants les les jeunes
gens dans dans les banlieux les les
jeunes gens même à l'intérieur de Paris
les jeunes gens partout qui peuvent se
poser des questions qui peuvent se
demander mais pourquoi l'Israélien
bombarde qu'est-ce qui s'est passe
pourquoi cette haine des musulmans et à
l'inverse pourquoi cette haine des Juifs
il faut pas comment dire laisser de
d'interstice pour laisser
ce comment dire passer ce poison qui
veut disloquer no nos sociétés
Ramous ta position elle est difficile
aujourd'hui ou pasre un influenceur et
de devoir faire des mine de rien c'est
tu réagis sur tout est-ce que c'est
compliqué pour aujourd'hui je je suis
créateur de contenu donc j'essaie de
divertir les gens je fais mais là là là
beaucoup dans l'actualité aussi donc
forcément oui non c'est pas difficile
moi je pars du principe où quand tu es
droit dans tes tes pompes tu as pas peur
de parler appeler à la paix c'est pas un
gros mot he tu as le droit d'appeler à
la paix tu as le droit de prendre la
parole dire j'appelle à la paix
j'appelle à l'apaisement j'ai de la
peine pour un Palestinien pour un
israélien et je vois pas où est la
position B menac menac là quand j'ai
fait ma vidéo j'ai reçu des menaces des
deux extrêmes mais comme je disais à
Antin c'est pas eux qui m'intéressent
moi je parle pas avec un terroriste je
parle pas avec les extrêmes moi je veux
parler à ceux qui ont encore un cerveau
non bien sûr tu en a reçu beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup SR beaucoup beaucoup
mais c'est quotidien malheureusement
mais moi je savais qu'en faisant cette
vidéo j'allais les recevoir c'est pour
ça que j'étais conditionné et je me
voyais pas continuer à faire ma petite
vie et me dire non mais je vais pas
prendre la parole je vais rester dans
mon petit siège doré puis je vais pas
prendre non non si je peux convaincre
des gens qui sont encore on va dire
récupérables si je peux convaincre des
gens qui se laissent embobiner par ah
mais je déteste celui-là par de
l'islamophobie l' sémitisme si je peux
encore les récupérer à mon ble niveau je
suis un modu comme tout le monde j'ai
aucun pouvoir je fais juste des vidéos
sur internet mais si moi je peux le
faire je par du principe où c'est mon
devoir et moi j'été éduqué par une
reenine et par un roi ils m'ont appris
donne sans attendre au retour donc j'ai
essayé de donner de l'amour il y en a
qui l'ont pris il y en a qui ont pris de
la haine tant pis il m'intéresse pas
est-ce que voilà n nousous c'est Mo on
est potes on s'écrit très très souvent
on c'est tout et c'est vrai que voilà
quand j'ai j'ai vu ta vidéo franchement
je me suis dit c'est il a il a vraiment
très très bien résumé la situation
j'étais j'étais fier de toi vraiment mon
frérot parce que tu sais comme je te
suis et voilà et Ramous ça c'est
vraiment un ami sait très bien que voilà
il peut compter sur'or
situation tu vois que tous les hommes de
bonne volonté en fait se ment dans dans
le même camp se mettent du même côté
c'est pour ça qu'il faut pas autoriser
par
exemple il faut pas ne pas réagir à des
à ce que disent les gens de la France
insoumise il faut s'opposer pourquoi
parce qu'en fait en dehors d'une posture
politique stupide c'est une incitation à
la haine tout ce qui peut troubler notre
société tout ce qui peut troubler
surtout les plus jeunes d'entre nous
surtout ceux qui sont les plus fragiles
qui ont le plus de de questions
auquelles parfois on ne donne pas de
réponse tout Cuxa tous ceux qui peuvent
mal les influencer il faut lutter contre
eux je vrais dire quelque chose
d'ailleurs sur la France insoumise
encore et et et et tous ceux qui euh qui
qui suivent la France insoumise il y en
a plein il y a des gens très bien qui
suivent la France insoumise aussi qui
voilà qui ont voté pour la France
insoumise euh je vais vous dire moi ce
qui m'a le plus choqué aussi c'est que
la France insoumise et moi moi j'aime
les gens qui ont qui parlent avec leur
cœur et la France insoumise pour moi ils
ont encore parlé
euh de façon à encore aller rechercher
des voix de façon calculatrice et une
fois de plus la France insoumise j'ai
pas senti d'émotion chez eux je suis
désolé j'ai pas senti d'émotions dans
leur tweet j'ai pas senti d'émotions
dans leur post j'ai pas senti d'émotions
lorsqu'il passait euh sur les sur les
chaînes de télévision il y avait pas
d'émotion et ça pour moi c'est
extrêmement grave parce que ce sont une
fois de plus le voit des calculateurs
qui sont des manipulateurs aussi qui
manipulent les gens sur les réseaux et à
la télévision pour justement qui a des
fins électoral et il ils sont vraiment
il y a une dérive moi quand j'ai vu
encore Mathilde Panau voilà qui sa'est
même pas répondre à une question et qui
qui n'a aucune émotion et qui voilà on a
l'impression qu'elle n'a pas du tout été
touchée par ce qui s'est passé ou un
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui parle plus d'
Matias que du drame qui s'est passé la
France insoumise pour moi ils se sont
ces derniers jours
disqualifiés complètement ils sont
disqualifiés pour moi la France
insoumise ils sont complètement
disqualifiés et juste il y a plein de
gens qui ont voté pour eux et qui
voteront pour
eux juste il faut Esser pas se laisser
berner aussi par la France ce sont
vraiment de ils sont très malins moi je
les ai reçu plusieurs fois ici mais
comme d'ailleurs beaucoup de politiques
aussi voilà mais certains politiques on
a quand même senti de l'émotion dans ce
qui s'était passé eux vraiment il y
avait aucune émotion et ils sont ils se
disent ils voient où est la brèche à
chaque fois c'est ça qui est fou Ramous
qu'est-ce que tu as pensé des des propos
de la France insoumis bon je vais pas
aller jusqu'au fond de ma pensée parce
que sinon je vais trop faire perdre 3
million d'euros ah ou donc je vais
rester très mesuré mais pour moi
certains politiques ont beaucoup de
responsabilités dans tout ce qui est en
train de se passer dans notre pays mais
vraiment beaucoup ont quasiment du sang
sur les mains parce que il y a vraiment
des des manières de d'avoir une posture
et là c'est il y a j'arrive pas à
comprendre 8 mai moi mais peu importe le
quand j'arrive pas à comprendre le 8 mai
oui mais vous non mais et on sent qu'ils
sont mal à l'aise et en plus ils font
semblant de pas être mal à l'aise ils
font semblant d'être hyper à l'aise avec
le sujet de contrôler d'être non au bout
d'un moment quand tu es responsable
politique tu es payé par les Français tu
as une responsabilité tu dois t'exprimer
tu dois dire tu dois condamner en fait
tu dois juste condamner et j'avais
l'impression que certains politiques ne
vouleit pas condamner n'avit pas envie
de condamner alors si c'est du calcul
électoral les mecs c'est comme le
casting de Plus Belle La Vie faut
changer là ça fait 30 ans là ça fait
faut changer là ça y est on est fatigué
et si c'est pas du calcul électoral
c'est vraiment qu'ils sont malades et là
faut vraiment aller consulter